who's my
bias oh my God I want to be the very
best are
St
okay today we are here with BuzzFeed to
take a quiz to find out which member of
straight kids we actually are all
right who do you think you get I think
I'll get Felix myself myself I think
I'll get me I think I think I'll get CH
B I think I get buried me to me all
right um should we just go straight into
it all right let's go first how would
your friends describe you
oh how would your friend very hard you
tongue bit is um funny oh creative oh
artist I'd say loyal I think that's what
my friends describe me oh you are
loyal creative next which hair color
suits your bias most who's my bias
myself black I love
myself I think silver yeah black I like
silver choose a hobby for your day off
tattoo ooh photography I'd love to get a
tattoo painting watching movies
shopping watching
movies but I can't I
want I want to get a
tattoo next choose a song to play on r
P
yes I want to be the very best that
noever
[Music]
do everyone done choose a stray kid song
that fits you the best I hate to admit
go the mirror pick something tast to eat
chin likes Sushi chin likes Pizza chin
likes rice cakes chin
likes sushi sushi
eggs oh I want to eat everything oh my
gosh eggs is always good
pizza's
good I like pasta I'm going to be
healthy and choose Sushi or
watermelon
water lastly pick an animal that
describes
you
squirel why is there a llama is there a
llama BuzzFeed L we talked about
this a you look like
[Music]
llama I
got artistic kind and super smart yes
you got CH you're autistic kind and
super
[Applause]
smart hey it says you're a natural
leader I was thinking
of who got
themselves do we expect
this artistic kind is super
[Applause]
small that was pretty fun did you guys
enjoy it no thank you BuzzFeed be sure
to check out our new album called
Rockstar out now on all streaming
platforms thank you guys bye byee bye
[Music]
galaxy